كان يعيش الحلم كلاعب
كرة قدم محترف في إيران ، لكن
خلال الأسابيع القليلة الماضية
، تحول وضعه إلى كابوس بعد
احتجاجات اجتاحت البلاد في
سبتمبر / أيلول ، اتهمت وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الإيرانية
الناصرة العدني بالانتماء إلى
جماعة مسلحة وجهت إليها اتهامات.  في
مقتل ثلاثة ضباط أمن في
نوفمبر ، تقول الحكومة إنه
اعترف بالمشاركة في
الجرائم ويواجه الآن 26 عامًا في السجن.
الناصرة العدني ينفي أنه مذنب
ويزعم أنصاره أنه قدم
اعترافًا قسريًا وتعرض للتعذيب
في السجن.  رسالة صوتية حصرية
حصلت عليها سي إن إن بمساعدة
مجموعة الناشطة ماملا كات يمكن سماعها
يناشد المساعدة من داخل
جدران السجن
مقابلة أخرى
كان في السجن منذ ديسمبر حيث
تشعر عائلته بالقلق على سلامته حيث
بدأت الحكومة بالفعل في
التنفيذ  أعدمت
الجمهورية الإسلامية يوم السبت الماضي
شابين آخرين من بينهم
بطل الكاراتيه محمد  جنون ماضي كرامي
يرفع العدد الإجمالي
للمتظاهرين الذين تم
إعدامهم وفقًا لمكتب حقوق الإنسان التابع للأمم المتحدة كرامي ، تولى رياضة
الكاراتيه في سن الحادية عشرة واستمر
في الفوز بميداليات في البطولات الوطنية الإيرانية
ولكن خلال الاحتجاجات المناهضة للحكومة
اتهم بقتل.
ضابط أمن وبعد محاكمة استعجالية
يُفترض أنها تستند إلى اعتراف بالإكراه
، أدين
وأعدم بعد شهر واحد فقط ، تقول منظمة العفو
الدولية إن محاكمته كانت
خدعة ومصيره أصداءً
للمصارع الإيراني نافيد أفكاري الذي سُجن.
لمشاركته في الاحتجاجات ومن ثم
تنفيذه في عام 2020. وقد ألهم تحديه
الرياضيين الآخرين للتحدث علانية ،
بما في ذلك بطل الكاراتيه السابق
مهدي جعفر الذي فر من البلاد في
عام 2008. تلقيت الكثير من الرسائل
من أطفالي الصغار الذين
يبلغون من العمر 17 عامًا و 18 عامًا  يفعلون ذلك عندما
يرون كل هذا
القتل والتعذيب في الشوارع
وكل تلك الأنواع من الأشياء التي
يخبرونني بها فقط  حسنًا ، أنت تعلم
لأنهم يعرفونني بسبب خلفيتي
وما إلى ذلك ، ويقولون فقط نعم ، أود أن أحب هذه
الحياة ، لقد انتهى الأمر من أجلي كما لو أنني
سأقتل نفسي يبدو أن الرياضيين في إيران
يخوضون معركة جديدة ضد ما
يدعو النشطاء نظامًا قضائيًا غير عادل
، وهم يوجهون نداءً على أمل
أن ينتبه المجتمع الدولي
، ولكن
للأسف
في هذه المرحلة ،
توقف التسجيل ، يقول أمير ناصرة العداني إنه سيكون لديك
الكثير لتقوله عندما يخرج من
السجن ولكن  في الوقت الحالي ، يحتاج إلى الآخرين ليكونوا
صوته وإلا يمكن إسكاته
إلى الأبد